so you did the thing everyone told you
not to do and now you've messed up your
skin barrier maybe you exfoliated too
much maybe you started too many
irritating ingredients at the same time
maybe you've had a cold and you've
rubbed your nose too hard and now your
skin's red and flaky weirdly shiny it's
textured your paws are more obvious
you've got more breakouts and the most
telltale sign of all products that don't
normally sting are stinging maybe even
water is stinging here is a step-by-step
guide on how to fix it this video is
sponsored by bondi sands i'll be using
some of the products from their everyday
skincare range as examples their
products are perfect for dealing with
this situation and not getting into it
in the first place step one stop using
irritating products let's go back and
understand what you did and what's
happening to your skin basically your
skin has 10 to 20 layers of dead cells
on top this is the stratum corneum often
referred to as your skin barrier the
cells in this barrier are dead but that
doesn't mean they don't have an
important function they act as a barrier
between your living cells and the
outside world so this stratum corneum
keeps water from evaporating there are
lots of important processes going on
inside your skin that require enough
water to work water keeps your skin
supple and flexible and it stops it from
cracking the stratum corneum also keeps
irritants and germs out this is its main
function it acts as a form of protection
for the rest of your skin if you
exfoliate too much you end up with a
thinner stratum corneum with less layers
it's like you're giving yourself a mild
chemical burn your barrier ends up
weaker and less effective than it used
to be so now things that didn't used to
irritate now might actually irritate
with this lesser protection so the first
thing to do is to stop sanding back what
barrier you have left so stop using
exfoliating products and the faster you
stop the faster you'll recover it can
take months if you're really unlucky and
you've been ignoring all of the signs so
here are some of the things you need to
stop using firstly chemical exfoliants
this includes alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic acid and lactic acid also beta
hydroxy acid also known as salicylic
acid also check the ingredients of your
toners as well sometimes they're not
labeled as chemical exfoliants but they
still have these ingredients in them you
also need to stop using physical
exfoliants the obvious ones to look out
for are scrubs and peeling gels but you
might also want to check other things
such as your towels your cloths and
pillowcases if they're a bit rough they
can act like physical exfoliants and
buff away your dead skin cells there's
also shaving if you shave you are
actually taking off some dead skin cells
when you pass the razor over your face
you'll want to be really careful with
this as your skin is trying to recover
also look out for enzyme exfoliants this
includes papaya and pineapple enzymes
sometimes these are in products that are
labeled glow on top of this you'll also
need to stop other irritating products
you might be using your skin has the
ability to repair itself but if you keep
attacking it it can't do that
unfortunately this includes most of the
active ingredients that people hype up
in skin care you'll want to stop using
retinoids these are vitamin a
derivatives like retinol retinaldehyde
and granative retinoid which are found
in regular cosmetic products you might
also want to put a pause on some of the
ones in prescription products like
tretinoin and adaptolene other common
ingredients you might want to stop are
ascorbic acid the classic form of
vitamin c and kojic acid which is a skin
lightening ingredient if you have
products with heavy fragrance that can
also irritate your skin now that you've
paused most of your regular skincare
routine we're up to step two which is
use bland products at this point you
don't want to add irritating products
into your routine you need to give your
skin a break but hydrated skin does heal
better and it helps your skin protect
itself so it's important to pick
products that your skin is less likely
to react to i'd recommend using
different products depending on what
stage of your healing you're at at the
start you'll probably want to use more
oil based and thicker products and
that's because some water-based products
can sting your skin when it's in this
very vulnerable state an example of a
product i'd recommend is the wonder
potion from bondi sands this is a mix of
really nice nourishing oils you can also
use a thicker balm product if you're
after something a little lighter that
you can wear during the day and it won't
look too greasy bondi sands have
released two fragrance-free moisturizers
these both have a really beautiful
texture they sink into your skin and
they protect your skin and hydrate it
without being shiny and greasy and so
they work really well during the day
under makeup or even just under
sunscreen again hydrating products can
sometimes make your skin a little bit
more irritated they can make your skin
barrier more permeable so if your
barrier is already pretty compromised
water-based products tend to sting more
this isn't necessarily bad but it's not
very comfortable so i'd recommend adding
hydrating toners a little bit further
down the line when your skin is a bit
more resilient step three is to use
repairing products now you need to be
really really cautious but your skin can
benefit from adding products with
repairing actives one of these
ingredients is niacinamide bonded sands
has the begin again serum which has ten
percent niacinamide with one percent
zinc the bondi sand serums are in this
really great packaging it's a lot easier
to deal with than a glass dropper bottle
it's much more travel friendly it's
spill proof it's made from recycled
material and it is recyclable the serum
itself has a thicker texture than a lot
of other niacinamide products on the
market so it's a lot easier to apply but
it still spreads really nicely on the
skin there are also some soothing plant
extracts that can help so you might want
to look out for chamomile and oatmeal as
well as centella asiatica extract
sometimes this shows up in the
ingredients list as one of these now
step four is to start again really
slowly once your skin has stopped
stinging as much it's gotten a bit more
resilient and it's recovered you can
start again with your skincare routine
now you need to be super cautious your
skin might not be as recovered as you
think and you don't want to have to go
through this whole process again so i
recommend using really gentle products
to start with don't start off again with
once a week pills or double digit
concentration exfoliants or one percent
retinol as you have now experienced it
can take weeks or months to recover so
you want to have patients going in so
for example you want to start off with
low concentrations don't use high
concentrations just for the sake of
higher concentrations like i said in a
previous video it is a myth that higher
concentrations are always better one
product i really love from the bondi
sands range is the buff and polish
chemical exfoliant this is a really
gentle product it uses gentler
ingredients like lactic acid and
gluconolactone these ingredients are a
bit larger and so their molecules don't
get into the skin as quickly as glycolic
acid so this cuts down on any potential
irritation by a lot with any product you
should try to introduce it really slowly
there are lots of different ways of
doing this so firstly you can try using
less you can measure out your product on
your hand and dilute it with a different
product like a moisturizer to help it
spread you should also start off by
using the product less often so use it
every couple of days instead of every
single day at first when you're starting
you can also wash off the product after
five minutes instead of leaving it
overnight and so that cuts down the
contact time between the ingredient and
your skin also make sure when you're
using irritating products that the rest
of your products are very gentle so use
things with moisturizers and soothing
products also use things with gentle
cleansers the bondi sands freshen up
cleanser is a really gentle fragrance
free low foaming cleanser it's really
hydrating and it clears your skin
without stripping it so like and
subscribe to promise you'll be nicer to
your skin and let me know any other
barry repair tips you might have in the
comments i did a video talking about the
bondi sans everyday skincare range for
the channel check it out via the link in
the description